par mon papa mon capable qu'est ce que
c'est julie françois est le facteur qui
joue en qui sans moi et ils ont une
boule ridiculement petit je vais aller
chercher la mienne
tenez facteurs à vous de jouer aaa
françois allez vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir
pour sûr le jeu qui après la pêche à la
ligne
c'est mon sport favori à lady factor
vous vous admire ou dans votre et fort
allez mais la concentration unis je fixe
intensément les quilles puis avec
acision avec décision je fais rouler
maboulou exactement comme ceux ci ont
regardé un joli 3 quilles vous adonner à
ce noble jeu de qui vous savez ma chère
amie que quand dans ma jeunesse j'ai
excellé une démonstration s'est dit cela
mettrait voulons donner monsieur du snad
à bercy françois hallé voyons un devient
le vent nord-ouest
oui ça c'est nord-ouest bon alors c'est
parfait attention hein monsieur non
monsieur dix neuf si je puis me
permettre un petit conseil
vous ne vouliez pas assez sur vos jambes
comme ça mon cher ami
une personne de ma qualité ne se plaît
pas elle arrête à droite en toutes
circonstances bon vous avez bien dit que
vous ne vous étiez pas s'y plier
chevauchant il s'agit bien de mes genre
d'acteur j'ai eu un petit coup de vent
non j'ai lancé la boule
je n'ai pas senti de petits coups de
vent je vous dis que c'est le vent ati
vous voyez je me suis même enrhumé
essayé moi aussi je peux mais évidemment
je les tiens applique toi tu as vu ses
c'est très difficile non ma chère amie
des c'est un petit peu le buste pas tu
en voilà et est plié bien les jambes
surtout moins jolie fille comme ça mais
c'est l'âge où est arrivé il ya eu un
petit caillou qui a renvoyé la boule
vers l'équipe s'est pas fait de petits
cailloux insu un dû selon vous êtes
jaloux c'est pas bien ça ne vient pas de
cailloux un paiement si vous vous étiez
plier sur les genoux comme julie acteurs
j'ai eu le vent contre moi julie a lieu
un caillou pour elle je n'en fais pas un
drame voyons très mal aller manquait
plus que lui et ses pasteurs champions
si vous n'y voyez pas d'inconvénient
j'ai apporté ma boule personnel enfin
casimir taboulé beaucoup trop grosse
pour l'équipe pour sur casimir tue le
tue un certain de faire tomber toute
l'équipe
oui d'abord aimer casimir casimir tu
prends la boule réglementaires comme
tout le monde allait de toute façon ça
ne changera rien vous allez voir tu veux
blesser tu es fou ça c'est celle où
j'écris lanceur de poids
tu dois faire rouler t'abuse rouler là
moi m'ont très bien aller il n'y aura
aucune différence de toute façon ça va
passer comme une lettre à la poste
os pas fallu de m il avait un facteur
aux mondiaux que je n'ai aucune honte
oui mille fois oui je sens que j'ai un
cas de conscience
les confitures
allez ça ira mieux après les vidéos dans
sa robe mais ne me retournais pas le
couteau dans la plaie voyance c'est
justement parce que je n'ai pas vider
mon sac que j'ai honte à vous savez que
je dois distribuer le courrier
1 ce que j'ai fait ce que le fait
toujours d'ailleurs et le plus vite
possible
seulement j'ai oublié une lettre et une
lettre pour casimir le bois voilà voir
ce que je faisais pendant ce temps là je
veux jouer aux quilles c'est pas bien ça
fait un nom comme démontré d'ailleurs
gontran votre rendu sonore mais
finalement faute avouée quoi mais dans
ses bottes il ya une suite mais je m'en
souviens plus du tout faute avouée à
demi pardonnée ah oui faute avouée est à
moitié pardonnée césar merci à toi à
moitié seulement
- vous en faites par je vous pardonne
l'autre moi qui est facteur au mercy
casimir tiens tiens je vais te donner ta
lettre tient bien la voici les nous l'a
vite merci mon cher casimir nous
habitent hors du village des fleurs nous
voudrions bien avoir tous en mannequin
de cire dans notre petit musée pour
notre fête annuelle
mais nous n'avons plus d'argent oui
pourriez vous vous entraînez pas rester
immobile et les envoyés pour la journée
de la fête de notre village celui qui
réussira le mieux
nous leurs récompenses seront bien dit
on ne peut pas les résoudre
on fit faire un coucou autres nous fera
très d'amérique il a gagné un point moi
j'aimerais bien connaître la récompense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes amis j'ai appris que la récompense
était un délicieux gâteau et pourquoi
êtes vous maquiller comme ça bien les
mannequins en cire ont souvent des
décrets assez marquée comme ça nous leur
ressemblons parfaitement là moi je suis
pas prêt et bien mes chers amis je vous
propose de demander aux enfants
d'arbitré afin de déterminer quel est
celui qui garde la possession le plus
longtemps très bien dans les métiers du
sang et quand ça venez vite nous aider
nous avons deux agneaux
asseyez sur vous sur le banc et regarder
nous avec attention et vous aussi chez
bien alors je vous propose de prendre
chacun une position qui vous est
familière oui par exemple moi avec mon
bocal de bonbons et à bonbons à la nasa
va très bien quant à moi je vous propose
quelque chose de très simple dans le
style la simplicité monsieur du stop ben
c'est pas l'idéal
la simplicité mon cher emile gelé dès
que je le désire donc vous fâchez pas
mention du snow dont eux quant à moi
françois j'ai pensé à ceux ci cette
position vous plaît tel mais c'est
parfait facteur 1
quant à moi avec deux ballons comme ça
là et moi comme ceci avec mondou bibouda
alors prêt pour le concours d'immobilité
attention cet interdit mais franchement
je ne peux pas c'est mon plus beau gars
qui met qui me chatouille le nez toutes
ces odeurs à 5 secondes pour te
débarrasses et ont pu vivre n'est pas
plus simple encore aller 1 2 3 4 et 5
[Musique]
casimir cesse de rire s'il te plait
monsieur du jeune homme qui m'a fait des
grimaces exprès pour m'empêcher de
gagner le délicieux gâteaux attention
tous les deux attention si vous
continuez moi je faisais les mines bon
j'ai une crampe en soit j'ai mal dont la
jauge portable écoutez moi bien tous
et toi aussi casimir et surtout de loi
je vous donne encore 5 secondes pour
bouger mais après ces cinq secondes tous
ceux qui ne sont pas figées dans ladite
et de choisy seront disqualifiés et
quels qu'ils soient quasiment d'accord
cinq secondes un bien 1 2 3 4 et 5
[Applaudissements]
j'ajoute il n'y a que les cinq secondes
sont écoulés et que je suis le seul à
rester immobile a dit donc aisé mais
c'est pas très régulier st enfin tu as
gagné quand même fait beaucoup courir
après tous tombés comme ça eh bien vous
m'avez dit tout à l'heure quand ma boule
était trop grosse pour vendre un jeu de
quilles à et alors là j'ai enfin trouvé
un jeu de quilles à la dimension de
maboul